un país hermano de rusia y al hacerlo
está poniendo en duda la estructura de
paz de todo nuestro continente
no hay ninguna justificación para nada
de esto esta es la guerra de putin
le he dicho al presidente ucraniano
selenski en una llamada telefónica hoy
que en estas horas oscuras
ucrania y sus ciudadanos tienen nuestra
col nuestra solidaridad completa
viendo los recientes desarrollos esta
mañana he convenido al cabinas de
seguridad para que el gobierno puede
debatir sobre esta situación y tomar
decisiones sobre cómo proceder de que
adelante unidos todos los ciudadanos
alemanes en ucrania a ellos les quisiera
pedir que abandonen ucrania por su
propia seguridad
el presidente del parlamento alemán a él
le solicite una reunión especial del
parlamento donde daré una declaración
especial
estatal como jefe del g7 esta tarde
estaré
reunido bueno reuniendo a todo el g7
como una videoconferencia buscando
una respuesta clara y coordinada a esta
situación estaremos coordinando de cerca
con nuestros socios internacionales en
la otan y la unión europea hoy con el
fin de poner el lugar sanciones más
severas en contra de rusia ahora y es
bueno que nos hayamos preparado para
esta eventualidad con mucho cuidado el
propósito de nuestras sanciones es dejar
claro al liderazgo ruso
que pagarán un precio amargo por esta
agresión todavía está por ser visto
pero será claro que putin ha tomado una
una decisión equivocada al desencadenar
esta guerra déjeme enfrentarme de
dirigirme a nuestros aliados en la otan
restaurant y ccoo es totalmente
asegurarles que entendemos sus
preocupaciones a la luz de estos
desarrollos muy bien y los respaldaremos
alemania está comprometida a la de la
cláusula defensa mutua de la otan junto
con el presidente francés sugiero que
los jefes de estado y de gobierno de los
países de los gal se encuentren
presencialmente para debatir la
situación esta noche viajará a bruselas